the stories that i'm about to tell you
in just a minute revolve around a
certain kind of
wasp that's quite common here in
wisconsin
and really across the midwest it's
called the yellow jacket it's smaller
than hornets it's actually smaller than
some other wasps like paper wasps but it
is
a really painful sting that you can get
from it can be dangerous to some people
if they're allergic and they are quite
aggressive
and so the stories i'm going to tell you
about are about getting stung
and and what what happened and why i got
stung and
and what the results were so
it's really two main times in my life
that i got stung by these these wasps
and
it's enough to kind of turn you off on
them i really don't like them
the first time was when i was four years
old
we were living in apartments in a suburb
here
in milwaukee called thiensville which is
on the
northwest side and i
you know we i remember we lived in an
apartment complex and there were a lot
of wooded areas
around and i was seeing these
these wasps going in and out of a hole
in the ground
so i went over to investigate to check
it out
and you know i thought it was kind of
cool to watch them going in and out and
in and out it must have been the middle
of summer i'm guessing when
they you know usually in spring they're
not doing very much
and they're building their colony and
then they it gets bigger and bigger and
bigger grows exponentially
and so by mid-summer they're in full
swing they're carnivorous so they're out
there
finding like carrying and other things
to eat they can also eat other
types of things and they're bringing it
back to the nest so
they they are usually going in and out
of one central
location here's what i did as a dumb
little four-year-old
i took a stick and i thought it would be
cool to shove it down there
and what do you think the result is well
you know they came flying
out and surrounded me and just started
stinging
and i all i remember of it is
you know yelling uh because they were
they were on me
stinging me and it hurt like hell i mean
it's like like little burning daggers
going into you
and i remember my mom running
picking me up and carrying me
as fast as she could away from the swarm
and into the apartment and i here's one
of the memories i was
looking down and i could see six of them
like two here two here two here and each
of them
had it's it's you know back arched and
was just stinging
repeatedly you know and each sting was
hurting and i was like wow this is
awful so that was quite an experience to
have as a kid
and i don't know what she did in order
to you know she must have given me
benadryl or something like that and some
painkillers
and you know i think i had a bath or
something i don't know what the remedy
was but
i learned the lesson don't mess around
with yellow jackets right
and definitely don't put sticks down
into holes
i'll mention another thing too um you
know i'm i'm a big fan
of bumblebees i would say i love
bumblebees almost as much as i hate
yellow jackets
and my sister unfortunately had a bad
incident with bumblebees i wasn't going
to tell this story but it just jogged my
memory
when we moved out to uh the hills of
delafield this this
subdivision that was more or less under
underdeveloped for years and years and
years
in between delafield and wales
there was a lot of open meadow space and
woods and stuff like that and so we
would take these walks
and we were in a vacant lot
that was you know kind of wooded and my
mom put my sister down
on a log that unfortunately contained a
bumblebee
nest it was like a rotting log and my
sister was probably so i was probably
about seven
she would have been about five or so she
must have been kicking her feet on it
and they came out and they started
stinging her
same sort of experience except that with
yellow jackets
there can be sometimes you know a
thousand two thousand
even more of them in the nest with
bumble bees it's
much much smaller and each bumblebee
that stings you that bumblebee is going
to die
because they only get to sting once and
so you know that was that was her
experience of that fast forward now
about
well i would have been in my 30s so
we're talking about
you know 30 years beyond that and we're
living in indiana
on my my family's land i i bought one of
the houses that my family
had my grandfather and two of his
brothers and
and you know their wives all retired
onto this place in indiana
uh north of rose lawn and built the same
kind of wausau
homes uh all you know basically within
walking distance of each other and
we we bought one of them and so you know
there was a lot of lawn to mow
and i'm you know i'm out there with the
push mower one day
mowing the grass and suddenly i feel
something stinging me
and i look down and sure enough there's
a yellow jacket and it's stinging me
through my sock
and i was like what the hell is this
right and so you know
i shut off the mower and i brush it off
and then suddenly there's a couple more
of them stinging me right and i'm like
oh this is bs i'm getting out of here
so i go inside the house and i was like
you know
these yellow jackets are stinging me and
you know my uncle aim was like well man
you probably
went over one of their nests they don't
like the sound of that lawnmower they
came out
and investigated and realized that you
were the culprit
and they started stinging you so you
should probably not mow the grass today
and i was kind of stubborn so after you
know putting some
some stuff on the stings and uh
changing you know uh the socks and and
you know
getting ready to go mow i was like well
i won't mow in that area
the the yard is big enough that there's
plenty of other places for me to mow
and here's where it got weird so i'm
mowing along and this is over by the
woods
and suddenly i'm getting stung again and
now it's not just on my legs now it's
like they're stinging
me on my arms and there's more of these
yellow jackets and i'm like
this is a good you know 200 yards away
from where i was getting stung before
how the hell are they finding me you
know what's going on here and
and by now i'm you know i'm in pain i'm
ticked off
i leave the mower there i go inside the
house and i'm like man this
this is not going to happen today i
guess i'll have to figure out another
time to mow the grass
so you know i'm in a you know i've got a
probably like 20 stings on me by that
time
and uh i'm not feeling real good because
of it
not that i'm allergic but you know when
you get stung that much
it's it's it's no fun you're there's a
lot of
pain throughout the area and yellow
jacket stings are way more painful than
a bee sting
so i'm in there and the next day i get
up and here's where it gets even weirder
so at that time it was summer and we
weren't using central air we didn't
actually have central air
so we had these screen doors right in
the the back in the front and we'd let
you know we'd open the windows and let
there be
all sorts of air flow through the place
so i go to the back door
and in front of the back door by the
screen door
there is a cloud of yellow jackets
just kind of floating in the air buzzing
around
and i was like what the hell is this
ar are they tracking me does there is
there's are they like
like crows where they know who the
person is who did something that they
didn't like
and then i go to the front door and
there's another cloud
of yellow jackets just kind of hanging
in the air
you know and it wasn't like uh a whole
you know
swarm or anything there maybe ten of
them but they were like on guard duty
waiting to sting me when i would go
outside
and so i had to go somewhere that day
so fortunately we had a garage that
that's adjoined to the
the house so i go downstairs and get
into my car
and open up the garage door go to where
i need to go
and there's no yellow jackets there so
they're not bothering me
and then when i came back back home
again
they were gone and you know it's
afternoon
and i i don't see any of them i still
didn't go outside that day and then the
next day i went outside and i i wasn't
bothered by them so i was like what was
this about so i go on the internet and i
look it up
and sure enough i found out that yellow
jackets are not just dangerous because
of
their stings and you know responding
aggressively
to noises or stepping on their nest or
anything like that
they emit pheromones and when a yellow
jacket stings you
it tags you as they say with a pheromone
that says come here and sting the hell
out of this guy
some more which you know makes sense if
they're trying to protect their colony
uh some scout stings i don't know uh
some animal that's gonna go and
bother them all the rest of them come
and sting that animal
and so that's what was going on there
was enough of that pheromone on me that
the next morning
they were still yellow jackets looking
for me waiting for me
wanting to give me you know their own
sting
then i read on further and it turns out
that if you kill a yellow jacket if you
crush it
which is exactly what i did when the
first one
stung me i i smacked it and then threw
it away
when you do that they also release a
pheromone that that says come here and
sting anything that's moving
so i really set myself up not not
understanding how their
their pheromones worked for getting
more stings and for this yellow jacket
surveillance that was was taking place
knowing that in the future i am very
careful around those
particular types of wasps i don't i
don't
kill them i just you know try to avoid
them as much as possible because i don't
want to
have a replication of that sort of
incident and i told my kids
to do that as well because i don't want
them getting stung
either the other thing that i'll say
about yellow jackets
is as i did research on them i
discovered that they're kind of a
you know i understand that nature does
things in all different ways but
some of those ways seem a little
horrific to human beings
so yellow jackets effectively
outstrip the carrying capacity of their
environment they
they begin with a nest that grows and
then there's workers that go out and get
things and bring it back
and it gets bigger and bigger usually
underground
and eventually it gets to the point
where there's there's too many workers
and they even start eating their own
larva and it's you know really
quite quite a thing they become
extremely aggressive by
august september if they're still around
in october
they're not usually as bad but they can
still be depending on what state you're
in
and how warm it stays they can be a
problem then
and you know i'll just say i understand
we shouldn't anthropomorphize
things like insects but i just hate them
i think it's in part from getting stung
as a kid and that other experience that
i had
as i mentioned i love bumble bees about
as much as i hate yellow jackets
and that is at least as far as the
yellow jackets part i haven't talked
about why i love bumble so much but
that is is why i'll i'll close on this
saying that bumbles are usually so
docile
that um you know not only are they very
attractive to seeing they're great
pollinators
you can actually touch them if you
really really careful and i've i've done
that
i've pet bumblebees in the past and it's
it's you know it's kind of kind of nice
to do
you wouldn't do that with a yellow
jacket so that's a good thing to close
on
you